your wife has been kidnapped
[Music]
they could hold her for 20 years or they
could kill her tomorrow I want to help
you you can't let her die we need to get
in there now
Echo 3 is geopolitical Thriller about an
American scientist in Colombia on a
research project who gets kidnapped and
held hostage by a young Colombian
militia and the American government for
a number of reasons is unable or
unwilling to secure her release the
White House want to hear about her they
were so brother and husband who are
highly trained Delta Force soldiers take
things into their own hands
you might see her as this Damsel in
Distress but what you find is that she's
tough as nails and willing to do
whatever it takes to get back to her
family
rescue they can't find this place you
don't know my family what makes this
show original is how deep it dives into
the characters and their relationships
as they fight their way through this
life and death situation of trying to
get reunited the truth is democracy is
dead in North America we reject your
influence I wanted to write a thriller
that was more nuanced than just good
versus evil I wanted these characters
that are lethal and dangerous but also
have emotional flexibility and
vulnerability she did nothing wrong
we're gonna find a way out of this which
I hope gives people the sense that
they're getting something special I
don't have a choice I have to get her
out
this feels much more like a sweeping
immersive 10 hour long film
you're hooked by the first episode and
then you're in it until the end you're
gonna see the spectacle of drama of
tense action it will be an edge of seed
experience and I don't think we've seen
anything like this before
[Music]